this is the fastest i ever have worked
for any vaccine throughout my third year
of career
one thing i knew that we do not have
time that normally
vaccine takes a number of years to
develop
so we have to work in accelerated time
frame
i like to do everything accomplished
like today there is no tomorrows
i work maybe 18 20 hour you know i
barely sleep four hours
people ask me you know if i'm tired um i
don't feel tired
nida patel is a senior director in the
vaccine development department
at novofax a small biotech company in
gaithersburg maryland
she and her team have been critical to
developing a promising covid19 vaccine
in just 10 months
i have you know molecular neurologists
antibody specialist immunologists and
associates in the team and they are all
very expert in what they do
so we doing so many experiments so many
analyses
at the same time one challenging thing
for me
having so many scientists working
different things keep them motivated
that okay we are getting there one more
experiment we're gonna know the answers
planning and communicating every
scientist
every day sometimes couple times a day
and being with them in the lab it's a
key to get to the point where we are
today
patel's passion to develop vaccines
against infectious diseases
led her to novavax five years ago
so my career started as a scientist
making
a vaccine at marymun my dad
has become handicapped at very young age
because of the tuberculosis
so that was my motivation to start my
first project as a tv
vaccine project i always been in a
vaccine area
lyme disease vaccine human
papillomavirus vaccine malaria vaccine
rsv vaccine influenza vaccines
our sweet vaccine was near and dear to
my heart as i have
was instrumental in developing
television map which is also called
synergies
that the only one available for
premature babies can save
from rso infection as a therapy if i can
bring our suite vaccine to the market
that would be my home run for my career
novovax's rsv vaccine attacks a
respiratory virus that kills tens of
thousands of young kids in developing
countries
it has twice failed in clinical trials
but the company hasn't given up on it
novovax has never brought a vaccine to
market
but the ones they develop share a
similar approach
using a viral protein and an adjuvant an
immune boosting compound
to elicit an immune response in the body
novovax produces the coronavirus spike
protein
by infecting moth cells with viruses
that contain the spike protein's dna
after harvesting the spike from the
membrane of millions of cells
the spikes embed in a tiny soap-like
particle
the resulting spike-studded cylinders
are the right
virus-like size for the immune system to
recognize them as a danger scientists
believe
so the three key features we were
looking into the vaccine
and we found one which has all three
first one was to have to have a protein
in a prefusion form the receptor binding
domain
are in upper position so we were looking
a strong s2 receptor binding
characteristic of our
protein as well as the stability of the
protein
at certain temperature and also the
immunogenicity at the same time
we made over 20 construct of a kovid
vaccine he found one that has a right
conformation
we found the right vaccine but there is
a lot more things that we are still
involved but we also look at the quality
of the immune response the protective
immune response
that that we our vaccine has generated
early clinical trials have been
promising after exposing monkeys to sars
cov2
weeks after they were vaccinated the
virus completely
failed to replicate in the animal's
noses
but the results from larger human trials
aren't in yet
and novovax is just now confronting its
biggest hurdle
scaling its vaccine manufacturing they
will have to rely
heavily on partners to produce their
vaccine
novovac says the experienced
manufacturers they will work with
like the serum institute of india will
help them create 2 billion doses in 2021
although up against larger more seasoned
competitors
novovax's covid19 vaccine may just be
their first to go the distance and make
it on the market
i can't wait to see this vaccine
deployed
and i probably the first one to get